how does a writer determine their
strengths
and weaknesses good question a lot of
times a writer's strength
um could you know i was thinking back to
writing partners
uh which i had at one time for a number
of years
and what our strengths were and my
partner's strength was coming up with
the idea
he would have a dream and say i have a
coffee in the morning
i've just i have our next movie and i
would be
that wouldn't be such a strength of mine
because i'm very picky about ideas and
you know they they come few and far
between for me not you know some people
are like
everything's an idea for a movie it kind
of isn't you have to work more at some
and others are definitely not you know
just boom
so his strength was coming up with the
idea
my strength was actually for us to be
able to sit down
and write the idea you know
structure all this kind of thing so and
he knew as well but i was the one at the
keyboard
you know and so sometimes a writer also
can have a strength of
dialogue so let's say a partner is like
really good with dialogue and the
other's good with structure
or both of them are good at both you
know but uh
i think when you the more that you write
and find
what your strength and weaknesses are
will be from
what notes you receive you know over
time and time again like well
structure wise this is off and that your
dialogue's great
uh your character's in you know what i
mean so i think
you can only find out what your
strengths or weaknesses by doing it
and then when you find a weakness try to
build upon that and
get better you know make it make it a
strength
sure so it's only by um getting feedback
and if you don't have a writing partner
sending it out for notes having sure
a friend yeah or writer's groups or a
consultant or someone to read it
and you know these things it takes time
of course and from let's say you write a
first script you're not gonna have any
idea what your
your strength is that you got to page
100 you know
and you may have all the strengths uh
possible but you also everybody has a
weakness that has to be built upon you
know i mean to be
to be uh to have it all be up at the
same level so what you want to do is
calibrate that and it comes
it'll take time but also like you said
it'll take i think from feedback
because you'll see time and time again
what um what am i not doing right what's
what's not hitting the mark
you know well your dialogue still isn't
it all sounds the same you know
i'm kind of weak at dialogue but i can
really craft a great structure
you know type of thing so i think after
two or three or more scripts maybe you
start to
say well i should really study dialogue
more you know like we were talking about
record it
and be out in the world listen to how
you know inflections tone diction things
like that so
yeah i'm always shocked at how
in i mean personal conversations like on
people's cell phones
it's i mean i guess you could get some
incredible stories from them i'm always
surprised that people are willing to
share such personal information oh sure
of course space
and you only hear the one side yeah and
i've heard some doozies
in my time just being in a store and
like oh my goodness
like right this person has either they
don't care the text came back
yeah i've heard all sorts of stuff you
know and
so yeah and you can only imagine what's
being said on that other side that's
great
you know which is a technique you know
like in the scene too where it's like
we don't you know we can only know
what's on this side and
in our mind you know type that's true
yeah yeah because it keeps like i'm
thinking who who is this other person on
the right
and usually it's someone that's not
doing a lot of talking
sure or they don't say hi honey or you
know it's
a you know what's going on here right
you know
that you would say well that's like good
i love how everybody says that's a good
idea for a movie
you go it's not what is it you know it's
like okay it's a kernel
which could be built but what is it
about you know what do we
you know or someone comes to your party
and says
hey you write scripts don't you yeah
when i can
and they go i got a good idea for a
movie you're like great i say you should
write it
they go i'm not a writer i said well i'm
you want me to write your idea they say
yeah it's great and then they pitch it
to you and you go
yeah okay i'll think about it and not to
sometimes you know
but it's like every idea is an idea for
a movie you know
if it's worked on yeah and sometimes
like like we were talking about
you beat the dead horse and you walk
away you're like it's not you know
you